und jetzt das heute journal
windsurfer richter und christian sievers
guten abend hinein
es ist ein schmächtiger junger mann der
den herrschenden über 1,4 milliarden
menschen den lenkern der kauf
kräftigsten volkswirtschaft der welt
keine ruhe lässt
er steht mit einem regenschirm in der
hand auf dem dach des reichstagsgebäudes
in berlin
er schüttelt dem deutschen außenminister
die hand er gibt gleich ein
fernsehinterview hier im zdf heute
journal
die regierung in peking registriert all
das genau und sie reagiert prompt wer
sich mit joshua wong trifft das soll die
schafe botschaft sein zieht unseren zorn
auf sich
josh homme ist einer der köpfe der
demokratiebewegung in hongkong die seit
monaten hunderttausende auf die straßen
bringt er ist für chinas mächtige eine
art staatsfeind und auch das zeigt
morgens reise nach berlin
er macht ihnen angst andreas künast
berichtet joshua bonn ist zu spät aber
kein problem
berlin hat gewartet im bundestag ist der
hongkonger politikstudent der liebling
der stunde
bonn trifft die cdu trifft die fdp
trifft eine stadt die ihn versteht
hongkong ist sowie berlin im kalten
krieg war der druck auf die
menschenrechte die polizeigewalt ich
wünsche mir deutliche worte der
kanzlerin an präsident
vergangene woche hat die kanzlerin
präsident an die rechte und freiheiten
hongkongs erinnert vor laufenden kameras
und danach chinesische menschenrechtler
getroffen sicherheitshalber ohne kameras
das war viel für merkel
und viel zu wenig für joshua war er
wollte unbedingt nach berlin
er wollte früher kommen aber sie haben
ihn vor seinem abflug noch einmal
festgenommen
joshua bonn ist 22 aber schon seit fünf
jahren das gesicht des hongkonger
freiheitskampf der sehr junge mann der
das sehr große china herausfordert die
paar sekunden die war gleich nach seiner
ankunft mit außenminister maas spricht
am rande eines berliner sommerfest
reichen aus für eine diplomatische krise
wir stellen fest dass deutschland den
separatisten aus hongkong einreisen
lässt um sich an anti chinesischen
aktivitäten zu beteiligen minister mars
hat sich sogar mit ihm getroffen wir
protestieren und legen eine ernsthafte
beschwerde ein
binnen zweier tage hat sich das
verhältnis zwischen deutschland und
china so rapide verschlechtert wie lange
nicht berlin findet sich plötzlich in
einer rolle wider die die
bundesregierung nie wollte in opposition
zu peking
das kann erfahrungsgemäß dauern
was ich erinnere daran als der priester
bell preis an news abo gegangen ist und
plötzlich die norwegische regierung
keinen fuß mehr auf den boden gekriegt
hat in china als david cameron den dalai
lama in downing street an empfangen hat
keinen fuß mehr gekriegt hat auf den
boden in china
und so möchte vonn berlin ein bisschen
antreiben und berlin bonn ein bisschen
bremsen
hongkong ist teil der volksrepublik
china
und ich glaube diplomatie kann man nicht
mit der brechstange erzwingen und das
muss auch herum und seine mitstreiter
verstehen die mitstreiter von herrn bonn
haben sich erst gestern wieder an die
hand genommen in berlin geht es um viel
in hongkong um alles laurent ist jetzt
bei uns im heute-journal herum guten
abend nach berlin
guten abend erwarten sie wollen auf
ihrer reise bei politikern um
unterstützung werben wie zufrieden sind
sie mit dem was sie da von der deutschen
regierung bislang höheren erhoffte sieg
vorbei party support wir hoffen dass wir
von allen parteien unterstützung
bekommen so dass alle menschen auf der
welt gerade auch in deutschland wissen
dass die hongkonger leid schädlich für
freie wahlen kämpfen und dass sie von
der regierung
wir wollen dass die polizei protest
aufhört und unser kampf für demokratie
gefeiert wird durch die unterdrückung
durch china nicht untergehen
der deutsche außenminister hat gestern
am rande einer feierlichkeit mit ihnen
gesprochen hat dafür prompt ärger aus
peking bekommen die kanzlerin redet
nicht mit ihnen hier in berlin sie war
aber jetzt gerade in china und hat dort
betont wie wichtig rechte und freiheiten
für hongkong sind reicht ihnen das sage
dass die kanzlerin präsident gegenüber
eine klare botschaft ausdrücken muss
kriegsrecht oder truppen zur richtige
antwort die hongkonger wollen einfach
durch freie wahlen wir müssen unsere
eigene regierung wählen wählen können
und das und peking muss dass das ist
auch das versprechen was damals in dem
vertrag über die chinesische regierung
versprochen hat und dieser vertrag ist
er riskiert unter den vereinten nationen
herr wollen sie sind seit sie zwölf sind
politisch aktiv sie waren mehrfach im
gefängnis jetzt auch gerade wieder
festgenommen worden in hongkong dann
wieder freigelassen
haben sie zwischendurch mal daran
gedacht aufzugeben
also in diesem kampf werde niemals
aufgeben
manchmal fühlen sich die menschen
unterdrückt aber wir lieben hongkong
beleben hongkong und unser kampf wird
weitergehen bis hongkong die heimat sein
kann wo wir nach unserem eigenen gusto
auch leben können
was würden sie sagen muss passieren was
muss erreicht sein damit sie sagen wir
hatten erfolg mit unserer bewegung und
jetzt können wir die bewegung auch
wieder einstellen dieser unterdrückung
hongkong das neue berlin und wir machen
unserem kampf weiter bis wir freie
wahlen haben das heißt die hongkonger
müssen das recht haben die eigene
regierung zu wählen wir müssen herr im
eigenen hause sein bis wir das erreicht
haben werden wir weiterkämpfen bis
hongkong der ort sein kann wo wir unser
eigenes schicksal bestimmen können
jetzt gibt es aber auch in hongkong
durchaus bürger die sagen jetzt reicht's
auch mal die wollen offensichtlich
lieber ruhe haben was sagen sie denn
opel ist wie hp sven polizei gibt
frieden zwei millionen menschen die
solidarität der hongkonger und zeigen
dass eines tages die hongkonger
demokratie genießen können das ist auch
unsere hoffnung haben sie manchmal angst
wir sind vielleicht ein bisschen müde
und ängstlich es gab ja hunderte von
aktivisten die finanziert wurden die
fordert wurden
das ist ein kleiner preis den wir zahlen
müssen aber das ist kein grund uns
bedroht zu fühlen oder nachzugeben
gegenüber der unterdrückung durch peking
was machen sie sollte die führung in
peking sich entscheiden irgendwann die
armee zu schicken
hongkong werden weiter kämpfen
jetzt ist die zeit das die führer dieser
welt eine klare botschaft an präsident
schicken dass der ansatz von tropen kein
ausweg ist vor einige dicke passierte
darf nicht in hongkong doch mal
passieren sagt jon bon aktivist für die
demokratie in hongkong
ich danke ihnen für das gespräch heute
abend denke ich danke ihnen das gespräch
aber aus termingründen kurz vor der
sendung aufgezeichnet was da heute im
bundestag zu erleben war wirkt ein
bisschen so als ob man ein haus bauen
möchte
die finanzierung steht alles aus
eigenmitteln keine neuen schulden klopft
sich der kassenwart auf die schultern
allerdings ist das ganze bislang ohne
dach gerechnet diese kosten kämen dann
halt noch mal dazu es ist haushaltswoche
im parlament bundesfinanzminister olaf
scholz sagt wie viele kommendes jahr
ausgeben will 360 milliarden euro
und wie viele einnehmen will 360
milliarden euro
das sieht erstmal sehr solide aus
stichwort schwarze null wie sinnvoll das
angesichts von null zinsen und -
aussichten für die wirtschaft noch ist
auch darüber haben die abgeordneten
heute diskutiert vor allem aber über die
tatsache dass die ausgaben für den
klimaschutz sehr sehr sehr teuer werden
dürften und dass die in dieser
finanzplanung noch gar nicht drin sind
aus berlin florian a
als olaf scholz am morgen in den
bundestag kommt brezeln die beobachter
noch in welcher rolle er heute auftritt
minister scholz der staatstragende
vizekanzler oder genosse olaf der
wahlkämpfer um den spd vorsitz scholz
hat einen unfertigen haushalt
mitgebracht die man entscheiden datei
fehlt vor allem die beschlüsse zum
klimaschutz die die koalition erst in
zehn tagen treffen möchte was heute afd
linke und grüne einmütig kritisieren der
bundestag wäre ja heute der ort um über
das sagenumwobene klima budget zu
sprechen das ist eine parlamentarische
zumutung
doch selbst für die grundrente die ja
immerhin im koalitionsvertrag steht
haben sie keine vorsorge im haushalt
getroffen das gleiche trifft für den
klimaschutz zu
und das ist ein armutszeugnis für diese
regierung was ist stückwerk was hier
abliefern und ich finde ehrlich gesagt
das ist keine ökonomischen keine
klimapolitische antwort im
haushaltsentwurf gibt dass wir nicht
brandgefährlich scholz spricht unter den
augen seines vorgängers im amt
wolfgang schäuble den die beamten dem
finanzministerium 2017 mit einem
besonderen gruß verabschiedeten einer
nachgestellten schwarzen null und scholz
beginnt seine rede ganz vizekanzler
risch stellt klar dass er schäubles
tradition fortführt das ist jetzt der
dritte haushalt dieser regierung den wir
miteinander beraten und wie die beiden
zuvor ist es ein solider haushalt der
ohne neue schulden auskommt wo schäuble
ist dank sprudelnder einnahmen aber noch
leicht hatte muss scholz tricksen um die
schwarze null zu erreichen bei einnahmen
und ausgaben von 300 59,8 milliarden
euro so zapf scholz die sogenannte asyl
rücklage an plus 9,2 milliarden und er
verpflichtet alle ministerien zu sparen
knapp fünf milliarden insgesamt dazu
kein wort von scholz stattdessen
wechselt er nach satz 1 in rolle 2
genosse olaf der wahlkämpfer
der etwa die grundrente fordert und sich
freut dass der solidaritätszuschlag für
manche bleibt ich sage ist es richtig
dass diejenigen die sehr hohe einkommen
haben diesen solidarischen beitrag auch
in den nächsten jahren noch leisten
da applaudiert wie während fast der
gesamten rede nur eine fraktion seine
eigene ja ich hatte gedacht es gebe 23
regionalkonferenz bei der spd aber das
was sie hier anrede abgehalten haben war
die 24 der regionalkonferenz für die
spd-fraktion und es war nicht die rede
eines haushaltsministers nach einer
halben stunde redezeit kommt scholz doch
noch zum thema klima der vizekanzler
wird pathetisch bleibt aber vage
genau wie seinen koalitionspartner jetzt
ist es fünf vor zwölf wir müssen handeln
und die bürger noch bürger erwarten dass
von dieser regierung und von diesem
parlament zu recht deshalb ist dieser
weg zu sagen wir müssen jetzt
ambitionierten vorangehen und dann
weiter denken im sinne eines brechen
können sie es richtig indem arbeiten wir
ein haushalt an dem noch gearbeitet wird
und ein finanzminister der schon mal
geprobt hat für die nächste spd
regionalkonferenz um den vorsitz am
abend in rheinland pfalz und wir bleiben
noch moment bei der spd die rheinland
pfälzische spd ministerpräsidentin malu
dreyer hat mal gesagt körperliche
verletzlichkeit einzugestehen wird von
vielen immer noch als schwäche gesehen
und nicht als mentale stärke
deshalb ist das eine schwere
entscheidung für jeden politiker immer
noch drei us kollegin manuela schwesig
hat heute große stärke gezeigt keine
silbe mit mir das mit einer nachricht
die die spd mitten in die suche nach
einer neuen parteispitze trifft
schließlich zieht sich überraschend als
kommissarische vorsitzende zurück grund
ist eine brustkrebserkrankung ihr amt
als ministerpräsidentin von mecklenburg
vorpommern werde sie aber weiterführen
viele frauen in deutschland erkranken
jedes jahr an brustkrebs viele frauen
zeigen dass diese schlimme krankheit
heilbar ist dass man dagegen ankämpfen
kann und ich habe schon einige kämpfe in
meinem leben geführt und werde auch
bieten kann führen und sind sehr
zuversichtlich dass ich am ende
gesund sein werde eine woche vor der
parlamentswahl in israel sorgt eine
ankündigung von regierungschef netanjahu
aufsehen im falle seiner wiederwahl
werde er das jordantal annektieren
damit werde israel seine souveränität
auf das gebiet an der grenze zu
jordanien aus denen dort leben neben
60.000 palästinensern auch 5000 israelis
in zahlreichen siedlungen
beobachter werten netanjahus ankündigung
als versuch mehr stimmen aus dem rechten
lager zu gewinnen in großbritannien hat
premierminister johnson erneut abgelehnt
bei der eu einen späteren braig sieht
termin zu beantragen obwohl ihn ein
neues gesetz genau dazu zwingt und zwar
in dem fall dass er bis zum 19
oktober kein neues abkommen mit brüssel
aushandeln kann
um diese vorgabe zu umgehen wollte er
erneut eine vorgezogene parlamentswahl
ansetzen
doch seinen antrag lehnte das
abgeordnetenhaus auch dieses mal ab und
der heftigen protesten verabschiedeten
sich die parlamentarier danach in die
umstrittene zwangspause in italien hat
premierminister konnte auch die
vertrauensabstimmung im senat gewonnen
damit kann seine regierung aus
sozialdemokraten und 5 sterne bewegung
nun offiziell an den start gehen
zuvor hatte ihm schon das
abgeordnetenhaus das vertrauen
ausgesprochen konnte forderte erneut
eine reform der eu haushaltsregeln
laut dem aktuellen stabilitätspakt
müsste italien seine schuldenquote
massiv senken
auch die strikte flüchtlingspolitik der
vorgängerregierung will konnte etwas
lockern
im irakischen kerbela sind bei einer
massenpanik mindestens 31 menschen ums
leben gekommen 100 weitere wurden in dem
gedränge verletzt
das unglück ereignete sich während des
schiitischen aschura-festes dabei
erinnern jedes jahr hunderttausende an
den tod des imam zu sehen ein enkel des
propheten mohammed möglicherweise
stolperte einer der pilger und löste
damit die panik aus als der
amerikanische präsident im april letzten
jahres einen neuen sicherheitsberater
brauchte er hatte den halten gerade
gefeuert da fiel die wahl von donald
trump auf ihn john bolton markenzeichen
walross schnurrbart trump mochte dessen
markige worte
er mochte auch das bolton trumps politik
regelmäßig im fernsehen verteidigt hat
bolton ist ein hardliner einer der für
militärische einsätze der usa in anderen
teilen der welt wirbt die herrschenden
im iran zum beispiel wollte er am
liebsten von der macht entfernen
jetzt muss sich trump einen vierten
sicherheitsberater suchen er hat john
bolton heute vor die tür gesetzt auf
twitter schreibt trump boltons dienste
würden im weißen haus nicht länger
gebraucht matti wissen ist unser mann in
washington immer guten abend was ist da
passiert zwischen den ball
ja man könnte sagen zwei mal hat es
gekracht zwischen den beiden innerhalb
von zehn tagen in der vergangenen woche
war boten empört über die idee von
donald trump die taliban terroristen auf
amerikanischen boden nach camp david zu
friedensgesprächen einzuladen
da hat man sich gestritten hier im
weißen haus und dann gestern abend noch
ein streit im weißen haus darüber dass
eben diese information über den streit
der letzten woche an die öffentlichkeit
geraten ist das wollte donald trump sich
nicht gefallen lassen gestern sind die
emotionen offenbar hochgelaufen boten
hat seinen rücktritt angeboten über
nacht an einen rücktrittsbrief
geschrieben
donald trump sagte jetzt er hätte ihn
gefeuert wie auch immer es war es war
ganz offenbar der tropfen der das fass
zum überlaufen gebracht hat trump soll
mal gesagt haben wenn es nach bolton
ginge hätten wir schon vier kriege was
heißt boltons rauswurf jetzt für die
us-außenpolitik
ja das heißt in erster linie dass die us
außenpolitik sich ausschließlich nach
dem amerikanischen wahlkampfs ausrichtet
und nach dem willen des präsidenten
unbedingt wieder gewählt zu werden im
nächsten jahr
er will nur mit wirtschaftssanktionen
und handelskonflikten handelskriegen
möglicherweise amerikanische macht
interessen durchsetzen aber eben nicht
mit militär arbeiten war immer der
meinung dass man mit terroristen und
diktatoren eigentlich nur umgehen kann
indem man ihnen auch militärisch droht
das ist jetzt vom tisch und deswegen ist
das natürlich auch ein signal an die
widersacher amerikas dass man mit so
etwas militärisch jetzt nicht rechnen
muss oder bestenfalls mit sanktionen
also es wird eine etwas friedliebender
amerikanischer außenpolitik werden aber
eben auch aus einer schwächeren position
heraus und das könnten amerikas
widersacher aus nutzen interessante
hintergründe zu diesem thema immer
herzlichen dank nach washington und
damit zurück nach europa man kann sich
an diesem tag wo ich auch mal
grundsätzlich fragen wie viel sinn ein
regierungsteam macht das aus 27 personen
besteht und was das allein schon mal aus
sagt über den zustand europas einerseits
vielfalt andererseits pöstchen proporz
die neue europäische union hat demnächst
sie
25 mitglieder sobald großbritannien den
ausgang gefunden hat die neue eu
kommission hat 27 kommissarinnen und
kommissare jeder mitgliedsstaat will und
bekommt seinen eigenen aus deutschland
kommt die chefin ursula von der leyen
und sie hat heute das kunststück
geschafft nicht nur all die einzelnen
staaten untereinander auszutarieren
sondern auch noch die verschiedenen
politischen richtungen und das
verhältnis von frauen und männern
anne gellinek stellt das team vor dass
in den kommenden jahren diese eu manager
soll
punkt 12 kommt ursula von der leyen aus
der kulisse in den pressesaal der eu
kommission das lächeln eisern die
vorbereitung perfekt die message
geschafft ich will eine kommission die
mit entschlossenheit geführt wird
die akute probleme anpackt und antworten
gibt den ganzen sommer über hat sie am
personaltableau gebastelt ressorts und
kandidaten hin und her geschoben um
möglichst alle zufriedenzustellen ost
und west große und kleine länder
parteien männer und frauen europa eben
26 briefe hat die neue chefin an ihre
kommissare in spe geschrieben mit je
einer to do liste zu erledigen von franz
paolo und der lieben mal geräte apropos
margarete die den investor steigt zu
einer der mächtigsten frauen europas auf
sie behält das wettbewerbsressort indem
sie sich mit donald trump über die
steuern amerikanischer digital konzerne
anlegt und bekommt dazu noch das power
thema digitales zweiter super kommissar
der niederländer frans timmermans er
koordiniert künftig die klimapolitik der
eu kommission
überraschend aber irgendwie logisch ist
die ernennung des iren phil hogan zum
handelskommissar eine geste der
solidarität gegenüber irland das am
meisten unter dem brett leiden wird ein
ire wird nun ein mögliches
freihandelsabkommen mit großbritannien
verhandeln eine kleine boshaftigkeit
gegenüber dem vereinigten königreich
ich kenne phil hogan als eines
exzellenten und sehr fairen verhandler
umstritten ist die entscheidung den
ehemaligen italienischen aussenminister
gentilini zum wirtschaftskommissar zu
enden
ausgerechnet italien soll jetzt
aufpassen dass die eu staaten nicht zu
viele schulden machen und ich schon
interessant wenn man einen vertreter aus
einem landes uns große sorgen beim euro
macht jetzt für den euro verantwortlich
macht müssen schon aufpassen dass hier
nicht der bock zum gärtner gemacht wird
in den nächsten wochen müssen sich alle
nominierten drei stunden lang vom
europaparlament befragen lassen
und es gibt noch mehr kandidaten die
durchfallen könnten zum einen haben wir
den ehemaligen justizminister aus ungarn
der also daran beteiligt war die
rechtsstaatlichkeit in ungarn zu
schleifen
zum anderen den vorschlag aus polen für
den agrarkommissar der hat aber gerade
zu tun mit der anti korruptionsbehörde
oder weil er gelder falsch eingesetzt
hat in seiner zeit als europaabgeordnete
und das europaparlament hat bis jetzt
immer noch einen kandidaten nach hause
geschickt die neue von der leyen
kommission soll mehr schwung nach europa
bringen erst einmal aber muss die chefin
ihre wunsch kommissare im parlament
durchsetzen
wir bleiben dran und jetzt mal
nachrichten kann selber wenn bei einem
immobilienkredit die zinsbindung
ausläuft dann dürfen sich die
kreditnehmer eine andere bank suchen und
für so eine umschuldung dürfen die
geldinstitute keine gesonderten entgelte
verlangen
das hat der bundesgerichtshof
entschieden im konkreten fall hatte der
verbraucherzentrale bundesverband gegen
die kreissparkasse steinfurt geklagt sie
hatte 100 euro verlangt für die
übertragung einer grundschuld auf eine
andere bank heute hat apple sein neues
iphone vorgestellt ein termin auf denen
technikinteressierte immer mit spannung
warten
allerdings scheint der ganz große hype
um die smartphones vorbei zu sein woran
liegt das valerie haller in frankfurt
und welche antwort hat apple darauf also
das liegt in erster linie daran dass
apple kunden ihre iphones länger
behalten als früher die innovation sind
ja auch nicht mehr so gigantisch dass es
unbedingt das neueste modell immer sein
zumal die geräte im vergleich zu anderen
herstellern ja auch ziemlich teuer sind
und den iphones technisch manchmal sogar
überlegen
apple steuert gegensätzen und stärker
auf andere bereiche als das iphone und
dennoch stellt apple chef tim cook
wieder ein neues modell vor das iphone
11 dass in vielen nur nachts etwas die
smartphone konkurrenz schon lange drauf
hat eine neue kamera mehr akkuleistung
und eine verbesserte gesichtserkennung 5
g standard fehlanzeige
das iphone ist immer noch apples
wichtigstes produkt heute macht es
weniger als die hälfte des umsatzes aus
es waren aber mal fast 70 prozent apple
mausert sich nun zum
unterhaltungskonzern ab november startet
der neue video streaming dienst apple tv
plus ein frontalangriff auf netflix
amazon und disney die ähnliche dienste
anbieten nur dass apple mit kampfpreisen
an den start geht
auch neu die spiele flatrate mit
exklusiven apple games das geschäft mit
den abos wird für apple immer wichtiger
schon heute zählt der konzern 420
millionen abonnements wozu auch cloud
speicherplatz und apple music gehören
das iphone hat eben seinen x factor
verloren
danke an alle zwei tage nach der havarie
eines frachters vor der ostküste der usa
sind nun alle insassen in sicherheit
helfer der küstenwache hatten ein loch
in den rumpf geburt und so auch die
letzten der 24 sie männer gerettet
das 200 meter lange schiff gehört einem
südkoreanischen logistikunternehmen und
hat 4000 autos an bord warum es kennt
hatte ist noch unklar
nur dass das klar ist ich bin kein
museumsstück hat karl lagerfeld mal
gesagt und allen eine absage erteilt die
ein lagerfeld museum wollten nicht so
lange ich lebe jetzt ist karl lagerfeld
seit einem halben jahr tot und es gibt
eine ausstellung mit bildern lagerfeld
hat nie fotos gesagt mit bildern die der
legendäre modeschöpfer selbst gemacht
hat von anderen rund von sich selbst es
ist der versuch von langjährigen
weggefährten nach dem tod einer
prägenden persönlichkeit das bild
zu prägen das die nachwelt von ihm in
erinnerung behält
um ein rein hat sich die schau in wedel
bei hamburg angeguckt ein bild das
aussieht wie gemalt und doch ist das
fotografie
es zwingt den betrachter ganz nah heran
zu treten um seinem geheimnis auf die
schliche zu kommen
für das perfekte bild war karl lagerfeld
kein aufwand zu groß da hat er mir beim
fotografieren gesagt wissen woher das
licht kommt und meiner dummheit habe ich
natürlich gesagt nein ehrlich gesagt
nicht schon zigmal vermeer bilder an
habe ich dann gemacht und also wieder
zurück in paris waren hatten wir noch
zusätzlich ein buch aus einer bibliothek
in die hand gedrückt über das setzen des
lichts in den bildern von vermeer um den
gleichen effekt wie in den bildern des
holländischen malers zu erzielen hat er
seine aufwendig gebauten kulissen
geschickt mit kunstlicht ausgeleuchtet
besonders gern hat lagerfeld werke
bekannter maler neu interpretiert hier
hat er sich vom amerikanischen künstler
edward hopper inspirieren lassen
sein langjähriger verleger gerhard
steidl war bei den meisten aufnahmen
dabei er hat 25 jahre lang exklusiv alle
fotos von lagerfeld gedruckt und mehr
als 100 bücher mit ihm gemacht
eine enge und herausfordernde
arbeitsfreundschaft lagerfeld schickte
gern mal faxe um fünf uhr morgens um
halb sechs kamen dann schon ein anruf
von ihm und er fragt dann haben sie das
fax gelesen ich habe gesagt ja natürlich
um antworten sind dann nicht gleich war
ungeduldig und
sagte dann auch bitte kommentieren sie
doch gleich nicht dann können wir
flotter zusammenarbeiten
lagerfelds arbeit war geprägt von den
unterschiedlichsten themen griechische
mythologie hat ihn besonders fasziniert
2011 gestaltet er den pirelli kalender
nicht mehr zwölf sondern mit 36 fotos
bei lagerfeld muss eben drei bilder pro
monat sein
vor seiner linse zu stehen das war
selbst für top models wie kate moss und
helena christensen etwas besonderes und
der franzose baptiste giabiconi ist
durch ihn erst zu einem der
erfolgreichsten männermodels geworden in
der ausstellung ist er allgegenwärtig
ein helikopter fabrik als monteur
gearbeitet nicht und hat in
kennengelernt also auf auf zuruf hat er
verstanden wie der handlungsablauf für
ein shooting sein muss lagerfeld ist so
sehr von ihm angetan dass er ihm einen
eigenen bildband wird mit während
baptist sich minutenlang ekstatisch
bewegt schießt lagerfeld unzählige fotos
den ausdrucksstarken bildern steht in
der ausstellung ein eigener raum zur
verfügung
karl lagerfeld ein visionär der seine
ideen am liebsten selbst umgesetzt hat
und wenn unternehmen mal wieder nach
einem aktuellen bild von ihm fragten
dann fotografierte er sich selbst mit
selbstauslöser so konnte er sicher sein
dass es perfekt wird heute wäre karl
lagerfeld 86 jahre alt geworden die
ausstellung im ernst barlach museum in
wedel gibt es ab sonntag zu sehen und
dann bis zum 24 februar uns gibt's
morgen wieder zu sehen für heute
verabschieden wir uns im namen des
gesamten heute-journal teams und
wünschen noch einen wunderbaren abend
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren falls
es ihnen heute ein bisschen zu kühl war
mit höchsttemperaturen zwischen 17 und
22 grad dann schauen sie sich mal diesen
temperatur vor schaufeln bis sonntag an
denn am sonntag erwarten uns in
deutschland höchsttemperaturen zwischen
18 grad an der nordsee und 27 grad am
oberrhein
das hängt zum einen auch zusammen mit
dem hoch friederike aktuell haben wir es
noch mit dem tief hans zu tun und dann
mischt sich ein ehemaliger hurrikan
unser wetter ein
neben nicht dorian dorian wird morgen
mit einigen regenwolken hier von
nordwesten bei uns in mitteleuropa
ankommen und danach gibt es schon wieder
einen ehemaligen hurrikan nämlich
gabriel und der wird unser wetter dann
am freitag bestimmt in dieser nacht also
fällt wenig regen und das allenfalls an
der ostseeküste
sonst ist es häufig klar dass bildet
sich nebel bei tiefsttemperaturen
zwischen zwölf und zwei grad und morgen
erwarten uns dann höchsttemperaturen
zwischen 18 grad an der nordsee und 23
grad zum beispiel in der lausitz nach
etwas nebel am morgen geht es erstmal
sehr sorglos aber das ändert sich dann
kommt ja der ehemalige hurrikan dorian
heran
der bringt regen wolken am nachmittag
dann zwischen sylt und dem emsland und
auch aus den alpen heraus kann es etwas
regnen
am donnerstag ließ regenfälle höchstens
noch in den westlichen mittelgebirgen am
freitag mit dem ehemaligen hurrikan
gabriel dann an der ostsee schönen abend
noch